welcome back to game sports coverage of
e3 2015
I'm Lucy James joined here by goth from
for access games here to talk a little
bit about XCOM - yes we are here to talk
about Siri excited to kind of show it
off here at the show
I am I'm very excited the team has been
working incredibly hard so it's always
very cool to be in the glitz and glamour
and show off what the team has been
doing and you have a really awesome
I like statue yeah that statue is
incredibly satisfying that actually is
based off of one of the first concept
pieces that we did for the game when we
were in pre-production when the creative
team was sort of looking for an
emotional inspiration for what the tone
of the world is gonna be so it's awesome
to see it come to life are you guys
gonna try and take it home I I have a
spot for it right outside in front of
Sid Meier's office it's just gonna be
blooming outside of the studio so it's a
little bit my ex come too that's why
we're here 20 years have gone past a lot
of stuffs gone down yes
stuff has gone down that's one way to
put it and I'm actually really excited
about our story it has a little bit of a
twist where we sort of looked at the
player experience we think that's the
most important thing rather than a
linear story that's written and a lot of
our players lost in enemy Unknown the
first time they played you can really
did you lose oh yeah okay yeah it
happens I lost to don't worry about it
that's okay didn't launched enough
satellites it happens and so we thought
that's actually a pretty cool kernel to
grasp onto that what if ex-con lost the
aliens would have occupied earth and
then 20 years into the future that
really gives us an awesome stage where
the odds are more stacked against you to
rebuild XCOM as a resistance force so
kind of from the from the ashes sort of
rises that's right you're the underdog
you're the rebels you're the good rebels
but you are you are the underdog and you
have to rise up from the darkness and
rebuild this organization so not sure
you're taking control you are the
commander again that's right well you
know that you you are still obviously in
control of XCOM but you have to find out
what what happened to the commander oh
of course
so we're I mean where's but where's our
base gonna be then I guess nowheres
really safe yeah in an alien occupied
worlds right so you now
have a mobile flying base our resistance
organization on the run so kind of kind
of Avengers II a little bit of anything
I don't know what Escom had at first if
you go back into the UFO defense that is
a no Maj to the ship that you could
build in the original lexicon yeah so
that other big company that's a little
bit bigger than us but yeah you're now
on the run you're rebuilding a
resistance and that's why you need a
mobile base yes okay so let's talk a
little bit because you guys are added
obviously a ton you a ton more new
phlegmon classes yeah
fighters let's talk a little bit about
our connection here totally um are we
are people seeing what we're talking
about so this is what you're seeing
right now are there's a few new classes
in here and when you load into a mission
and XCOM you're now kind of the tables
are turned
you are now invading the alien occupied
cities so they don't know you're there
you're actually under concealment that's
when you see that little screen shader
around the border and unlike enemy
Unknown you can now get the jump on the
enemy and and and pull off ambushes
there's really really cool new classes
that are evolutions from enemy Unknown
yeah
you have the Ranger you're gonna see him
a little bit she has some tricks up her
sleeve if she wants to get up close and
personal and you have another new class
such as the specialist you might notice
that little floating robot in the bottom
right corner yes that goes along with
her and that gremlin can do really
really cool stuff such attacking oh wow
so did we just see that I'm sort of half
distracted by the crowds of people
actually running into my crowds are all
flocking to see XCOM - thank you come
see it yes so this is the Advent the
Advent is the lives of the front for the
alien occupiers they're upholding order
the civilians that you saw in that
previous shot they're coming to these
cities they're humans they're coming to
these cities they feel like the aliens
are their saviors they've cared disease
everything is great in the cities and
now it's up to XCOM to reveal the truth
yeah to kind of you know the wolves been
pulled over the earth sighs that's right
thank you as they seem that's right and
in this moment right here X comes about
to take off the gloves and throw the
first blow oh they're set we're setting
up a double ambush
shot we're gonna move the Ranger into
position and you'll see here she's gonna
she's taking her target they're not
alerted they don't know that XCOM is
there and you can pull off these really
cool maneuvers BAM take off first unit
since you set up overwatch on your other
two targets this is seamless Trent this
seamless scenario can play out and this
allows you to get the jump on the enemy
before they even know you're there so is
this a kind of feature that was
requested by funds or was it just
something that you guys wanted to put in
you know we were really happy with core
XCOM combat we didn't want to lose that
after you go through these concealment
situations you're still gonna have
classic cover based system the two
action system lots of soldier abilities
to play with an alien abilities to
counter but because we were in this sort
of resistance focused world we wanted to
have a layer built on top of that
foundation that could be a new mechanic
for the fans to play with and it also
addresses some fan feedback it allows
you to get the jump on the aliens before
they have their scamper yeah so the game
features are procedurally generated
levels
I'm really glad that's actually one of
my favorite features it was a probably
the most the highest court pillar for
design yeah to get that holy grail of
how can we ensure you will never see the
same layout twice and the team has
pulled it off on XCOM enemy Unknown we
had players that played hundreds of
hours and they would eventually tell us
I'm starting to see the same map choice
we now have a system that ensures that
doesn't happen now I think you'll like
this alien haha Wow it's kind of like oh
wow so I mean I see if she can just so
you can do that what and she can do that
you see you guys had a lot more fun
designing we did we did we put our
designers in these nightmare incubators
and they wake up and say I want the most
terrifying thing to happen it gave them
a lot of cheese before bedtime that's
right that's right
and getting getting yanked out of cover
is probably the scariest oh I'm sorry
that was our Ranger yeah so because
you're a resistance they're now pulling
together any resources they can find and
a machete sword can be one of them so
they have to get really close and
personal to take out some of these
aliens and the aliens are really really
tough and dangerous as you saw with the
viper that these abilities that they do
are
very very very scary I mean just see
here grenades taking a car as well a lot
of collateral damage and there was three
troopers on there that's like the
classic moment where ex-con moment we
are like I must take these guys out all
at once this I'm sorry I'm sorry I was
just my task is the other procedurally
generated levels difficult to implement
oh yes it was a challenge but we came up
with with a really cool system it's
really a mix of the lessons that we
learned on enemy Unknown you still see
really beautiful maps like this a lot of
elements are still handcrafted by our
designers and artists but we have a
system where things can patch in if you
can imagine like a patchwork quilt yeah
but you have the cold itself and then
the patches can change on that quote so
you have these different segments that
are really interesting so a big thing in
the in enemy Unknown is was that you'd
kind of camp a lot yes you'd find a
really you'd find high ground you find a
solid bit of cover and you would just
try and pick off the people well for me
so that better we can see how it's a
smart tactic yes but in X come to it
seems like the environments will easily
destructible kind of forcing you to get
out and get moving
yeah I mean the environments are very
brittle it's it's dependent on what type
of weaponry you have the enemies we're
facing here have advanced weaponry so
the cover will go away a lot faster and
actually when you have your firefights
in buildings now with XCOM - if you
throw an explosive device or do
something really strong the floor can
actually get taken out from underneath
you very different than enemy Unknown
you'll see your soldiers fall down and
so you always want to be aware of that
when you're on height yeah sure what did
we just see that we just saw yeah you
actually just saw an example of our
mission objectives and we also changed
the way that the goal of combat works in
XCOM we still love the idea of killing
all the aliens and that is always a
primary objective but you have a
secondary objective that pushes the
resistance forward right and that's
procedural it can change it's not
scripted like enemy Unknown so you may
do something like blow up a monument
like you're seeing in this situation or
you may recover Intel for the resistance
or hack a workstation speaking of
hacking you just saw what the specialist
does yeah you can send out the gremlin
we've now taken over an enemy unit which
is a turret yeah and we're turning the
tables on on the admin
taking them out with their own weaponry
they didn't even see it coming so I see
I see in this kind of scenario where
aliens taken over they kind of want to
keep us oppressed resource is gonna be
hard to come by and I'm some resource
gathering is a huge part yeah so how is
that gonna play out it is maybe
scrabbling yeah that that's the magical
thing that's why I love XCOM so much
because what you're seeing is just one
half of the game yeah we talked about
the mobile base there's obviously going
to be an amazing strategy layer on top
of that that we're not talking too much
about right now but there will be
resource gathering with enemy within
you kind of gotta introduce the wow this
guy yeah that's actually a girl but yes
that is a crazy new monster that's the
evolved bruiser cur yes
and like enemy Unknown she's way bigger
now you do not want it to let her get
close to you know what you'll see in a
minute why oh all right we're gonna keep
an eye on up I was just gonna ask you
about the so we kind of had the mech
suits in the augmentation in enemy
within is not gonna make her ten um
you'll have to see you know this is
really a clean slate and again ex-con
has some resources that are tougher to
get by so we're really starting fresh
with XCOM - that is why you don't want
to let to get serger next to you so
she's been taken out and this is a
really cool new feature of of x2
there's perma death I think you told me
a little bit before you had your unit so
you can lose bad experiences with now
you can pick up those units you love put
them over your shoulder and take them
off the battlefield oh that's right was
that was that as a response to too many
people tweeting when they lost their you
know they they made the significant
other in the game yeah kind of lost them
yeah it might be a false solution
because they can still die but now
you're just taking their bodies off the
battlefield
and mechanically it's interesting
because you don't as a freebie get their
gear that could been really valuable you
now have to make a decision of I'm gonna
put my gun down and put her put him or
her over my shoulder and get out of
Dodge yeah I mean say obviously you got
quite a why was he gonna try and take
out the helicopter oh she's gonna try Oh
wonderful so I mean you have a very
strong community leader and oh my gosh
what kind of things that they've
requested have you put in
I mean multiplayer is obviously yeah a
big thing your fans love yeah yeah we
have we have multiplayer and the cool
new change with multi
there is we're gonna have procedural
maps when you have the when you have
these one-on-one matches with your dream
squad yeah the community is everything
to us it is so important to hear what
they have to say and it's nice you know
design we're so very design driven
that's game play first player experience
first but to hear what the community is
saying and and take a look at that
things like procedural maps is a great
win win yeah the community was telling
us we want more maps we want more maps
and we said alright we're gonna build
you a system where you will never have
Maps exhausted you won't see the same
layout twice and we're hoping they
really like that so easy XCOM is
franchise it has a lot of legacy on PC
yes I'm gonna ask the question I'm so
sorry
what question is that I don't know sir
is it gonna come to console you know we
are for access when we looked at what we
wanted to do we wanted to say laser
focused on our platform that that we
have a strong pedigree on yeah
and this allowed the team to make the
best game possible on that platform and
then when you look at things like
modding we really want to provide this
robust modding suite for the community
again to make new worlds to do partial
modifications total conversions they're
gonna have unreal editor access we're
going to support through Steam Workshop
we think there's a really strong future
there to build even more modding and X
come to is a great systemic game to do
that with well especially but now that
games like fallout 4 gonna support
modding on consoles it's a kind of
Avenue that sounds like some dark magic
that I can't wait to see how they play
off no idea you know I don't know yet
but that's that's interesting you know
what I'm sure they thought it through
yes yes thank you so much for joining me
guys make sure you don't go anywhere
because we go so many more games coming
up on the GameSpot stage here at e3 2015
I'm sad it's the last day I can't
believe it but don't go anywhere